uh are you still on only fans no no but
you mean I'm mad as girls are only fast
how does that go because there's a lot
of people who do that tiger does that I
think Adam's doing that a lot of there's
good money in that huh
is it is it like when you say you manage
them like what do you bring to the table
you retweet their [ __ ] like you repost
their [ __ ] on your page like we double
their numbers so you're like the
stimulus package if a girl's got an only
fans account and she's not popping she
could sign with you and then you'll
bring the numbers up yes sir excuse how
many uh girls are you helping
at the moment on the uh on the of
we got a roster you got a roster we got
a roster let's say from like 50 to 80.
Jesus Christ you're like [ __ ] Bang
Bros bruh
Jesus you ever [ __ ] on the only fans
ah
no yes sometimes like I I don't gotta do
that [ __ ] but you've done it before of
course yeah okay fair enough
hey shout out to only fans man it's a
good hustle it's definitely a good
Hustle
Ty I think I know Tiger's got his like a
t-raw thing that's booming so